and it goes from us
if you look at the meditation
film where i'm explaining about uh
throwing without touching then
uh this is uh an extension of that but
this
is if you like meditating while you're
still
awake
many i've been doing this for over 30
years what i'm going to show you now
it's called one-handed sword and it
defies
uh it defies well
defies angles but the angles are created
in one's mind as well as what people can
physically see
so talking really on the meditation uh
films that i made it's
it's linked to this because so
at the moment we're in a pandemic and
we're in lockdown
this was one reason for doing these home
films but i want to really give you a
present
and the present is for two things
one is now's a good time because we
can't
touch people we can't and you can do
this at home
if you've got family members or you're
living with somebody
you can try this now
if you look at those senses films you'll
find one where
he holds the joe out the arm's length
and there's about four people pushing it
and when and he's smiling or he seems to
be having a happy face
and then he just bows like this and
throws them down
i can't do it with the joe
because i don't have any con enough
confidence
but i've been doing the ken for about i
would i would guess
30 perhaps more than 30 years
so i'm going to explain today how you
can try this in your home
the reason i'm also celebrating this
information is because you've chosen to
become a
contribution to the patron side
and so therefore you're giving trust in
me
and i'd like to share some depth with
you that i don't want to share with
other people who just want to
take it um psychosensity
said once that tony johnny well i'm a
student
and when i replied but sensei i haven't
yet been to obama
he said the obama students don't follow
me all around the world like you do
and to me you're dedicated you go away
with your information
you work on it as an individual and you
come back and the next time i see you in
another country
you've advanced so therefore you know
in my eyes so that was a great honor
and something that i'll obviously always
take with me
to my dying days and um
but i never would dare talk about this
type of stuff to him
because he was a very technical man so
you'll have your techniques
and we must have solid techniques
this is a separate thing this is for you
i'm a very much an individual person
i like being an individual person i hope
i'm talking to
individual people who think the same
so i've just hit my 100th youtube film
i can't believe i've made a hundred of
them
and this is so it's a celebration
hundred years i hit that
i'm not a hundred years sorry hundred
films i've hit that
and now i'm going to go into the depth
of
what i call a wide awake meditation
why try this is
because i want you to realize that
we we were about to talk about this in a
lot of films
you need to uh lower your ego we all
have an ego and we need to
face it head-on sometimes and this
particular technique
and i call it technique because i'm
going to explain it to you
the technical part as well
the technique is there but
you have to face it
so if you it's a really good ego busting
technique and you'll know the moment i
ask you to try and perform it
take if you've got a family member
you're in lockdown or
a partner or if you are going to train
we can't touch each other at the moment
but so this is a really good one
what you do is
if you're about to try so let's say i
i call my partner and i say oh i want
you to
do something with me i i'm testing out
some
stuff in my head uh
you'll have a what i call a ping pong
method going on in your mind you'll be
questioning
whether you can do it or not
you're worried about if you're going to
embarrass yourself or not
this this is um what i'm talking about
the ego
you're worried about being like making
yourself like a fall
when it doesn't work what nine times out
of ten it won't
you're going to have to come up with an
answer
perhaps i'm not in the mood today or oh
i need to work on it more
all these are excuses
one day you will know the same as i have
i remember teaching in a seminar in
athens
and i saw this really big strong guy he
was
i don't know downgrade but i don't know
what level now
and he was pounding everybody in the map
showing them how
good his aikido was compared to
everybody else
and i could use it see that he was using
a lot of power
you know he was a very proud man
and destroying people really
now perhaps his ico is that good that he
can do it
so we we had a i said a 10 minute break
and i i just had i said would you come
over a moment
and um i'd like you to do something and
i just put my
can out like this and you stand
at this angle i'll show you
you stand at this angle so i'm looking
if this is uh looking at you at the
camera and
this is at 12 o'clock six o'clock then
over here i'm going to 10 o'clock so my
body
is at 10 o'clock i mean i mean how many
then once you understand it you can
almost stand completely the wrong way
i have shown it i don't know if it's on
film anywhere but i've shown it where
after it working i actually take my hand
away
and i rest it on my arrest
on my grind just here
the indent in the groin i've rested
there
i take my hands away and they still
can't push it
so remember i can't do it with the joe
and four people but i can do it with one
person but i have to know when
when it's correct my mind will now
i'll go today is the right day
don't ask me why
but something internally remember
the film that you can always dot
in and out of these different films but
there's one of the
films that i'm talking about in you know
the meditation it's about finding your
inner self
connecting with your self most of the
time
we're far too busy with our outer self
to want to be bothered to connect to our
inner self
okay so you stand in hand me
you bring the can out as soon as that
you have
one hand on it in the upper position
here and you extend it out
so i'm going to come in closer to the
camera so you can see
they you ask them to come to the side
and they take two hands so i'm now the
the pusher they're in hand me
get they can get down if they want you
know
side view they can be down here if they
want
to get a good strong push
back foot dug in wider stance
you are holding the handle end
so when it comes out do a close-up
when it comes out i offer it
but i offer it with my hand a little
high so i'm i'm physically holding it
here a little higher
as they come you lower the tip to
parallel
the hand is still a little bit higher
than the navel
and as they take both hands
you just sink this hand down
and push the can away from you so it
sinks down and extend okay
sink down extend
that is the plug that is the key
to the technical part okay if you don't
it's a coke you move okay
a coke can move so it's down
and out extend down and out and extend
okay same as you do
a coke you a coco
a coke a coke
okay so this is what i'm doing
even though let's supposing i'm you even
though i don't know what i'm doing
i'm standing in hammy 12 o'clock
i am at 10 o'clock only my turn my head
obviously
as they grip down
and forward down and forward
okay so you're plugging into them
you've now asked them to push with both
hands
evenly
once you understand this your mind will
scramble all the information
and it doesn't matter if they're pushing
evenly or not
you can almost i'll show you them here
you can almost sort of say can you hold
like the ken and you can off
you can offer it grab it with two hands
this wide so it's better to show than
what you want
can you just grab the ken like this two
hands wide
so you get a good push
a good push a good a good grounding with
their body
they're going to be pushing right and
they're there this is what i call a
ready position
so i'm showing you like that it should
be that the normal
ken why they're here it doesn't matter
if they push
there or there because you've gone down
and extended out a little bit what that
does is
that connects mentally with them and
physically
you're only doing it like you take a
normal plug and you go and plug it into
the electric socket
it's you plugging in
if you've got doubts then all you're
doing
is what i call an empty action an
empty action and the chem will be
loose wobbly it won't be grounded
when you do it correctly it'll feel as
if when you come down like this
when you're off wet it'll feel like it's
going into
concrete and the concrete is setting
very rapidly
you'll just know so get one of your
family to sort of say could you come to
the side
grab it like this
hands wide apart and wide apart
getting a good position square body
square body good position because i'm
going to want you to push
this when i tell you so then you tell
them when to push
remember you're building up you're
building up
okay can you come and get the can
as they come it leads them in
as they come it leaves the men
extend down and out
so play around with this we're going to
go into depth
about the mind
the ego the the quicker you can get rid
of the ego in these techniques
the faster the understanding yes these
are long
films that we're making now and you
might need to dip in
and out because everybody's in a rush
it's a long term thing it might not work
today it might not work for a year
but what it will do is it'll start a
process in your mind
of thinking about your aikido and how
you approach another person
mentally how you're sort of like look at
them and
weigh them up in a business conversation
you use your iq
in daily life this is all about making a
connection with other people
being more astute being more aware
controlling your ego feel your ego
rising
well i really want this to work well of
course we do everybody does
but
down down out
down and out
down and out your both feet should feel
firmly even now 50 50 on each
foot not more on the front foot and less
on the back
not more on the back and less on the
front the hand goes
down and your body goes
down even if you see me going forward
the weight is even so i'm now
50 50 50 50.
okay don't worry about if the ken's
slightly high it doesn't have to be
parallel
you know it needs to be it can be
adjusted
once you've plugged in okay
let me know how you go on we'll talk
about this in a lot more depth
as as we as we go standing
meditation you're clearing your mind
thank you for now
don't worry